it's a future that you might imagine if
you were 13 years old growing up
sometime in the 1980s and you were all
alone in your room reading Omni magazine
and that's that's a I spent many hours
exactly like that when I was 13 the
1980s so uh yeah the you know there's
there are pieces of that character that
are definitely me you know he he's a
jilted by a girl that he loves and and
imagines it an elaborate revenge fantasy
you know that also involves him
improving himself and so that's his
that's his vision of the future is that
you know technology will will save him
and somehow make him more powerful yeah
oh and really just sort of even him up
with everybody else yeah and there were
definitely times particularly in my
early teens where you know I felt I felt
like that not necessarily that I was
going to build and command a robot army
but you know just the promise of the
promise of technology you know is
frequently about evening evening the
score making things accessible for
everyone the way that they they haven't
been so I think the best the best kind
of you know my favorite kind of futurist
thinking is that kind of futurist
thinking so yeah you know I may I am a
fan of technology and science and I know
there are you know people there are a
lot of people who don't feel that way
who fear technology in progress and you
know they don't necessarily have to be
Luddites to be that way you know they
may use cell phones and and computers
but at the same time they feel like
technology is you know a Pandora's box
that has been opened and and all of the
ills of the world are gradually
you know destroying our society and
tearing us apart and isolating us and
destroying the planet and you know maybe
they're right but I kind of think that
if you look at progress in particular
technological progress if you take any
sort of rational long view of what has
happened so far you would have to come
away with the opinion that overall it's
been good for humans here on earth and
you know I fully expect that that trend
will continue and certainly there are a
lot of challenges you know there are
millions of gallons of crude oil pouring
into the ocean right now and that's a
terrible thing and it's a terrible side
effect of our technological footprint on
this planet but you know I believe that
we can face these challenges and and I
believe we can solve these problems and
I think with I think that we will
because that's what it's sort of what
we're here to do
yes I was very flattered to see that you
asked him that question about the song
and that he had heard of it and had an
opinion of it you know yeah I would like
to say to him is I apologize that I got
the math wrong I have been informed by
numerous mathematicians both expert and
armchair that I am actually describing a
Julia set and not the Mandelbrot set I
still don't exactly understand the
difference so I apologize for acting as
though I was an expert on the subject
when in fact I was mostly just mining
wikipedia and doing my best to put it
into into lyrics for a song